they interview mark zuckerberg from the  movie social network he says did you  watch the social network he says i did  want to watch a social network what'd  you think about the movie how accurate  was it you know what his comment was he  says we certainly showed a lot more  partying than we did  we didn't party that hard it was hard  work how's he doing today maybe the most  hated guy in america but the guy's worth  100 some billion dollars you're gonna be  worth you're gonna be pretty hated when  you're worth a hundred billion dollars  no matter what you do know how you make  your money i don't know a certain single  person that's where that kind of money  that's loved by everybody